[Music]
casey is in little rock hi casey how are
you
fantastic how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
uh yes sir i'm trying to get your
insight um
i have about eighty thousand dollars in
debt um
uh my my highest is my student loans for
about sixty thousand
and last year i bought a car uh
about there's about 21 000 right now i
have about
19 364 dollars left on it
um trying to get your insight do you
think i should keep this car i make
about
53 and 100
no no no
no you need to get rid of the car you
should have never bought the car what
kind of car is it real quick
uh 2020 hyundai accent hyundai accent
okay
all right yeah we need to trade this car
in we need to sell it actually
and then go get you a cash car you have
any cash in the bank right now
uh just uh one thousand dollars yes sir
all right uh we're about to go to uh a
commercial here but
once they get done talking to you i'm
gonna have kelly stay on the line
i'm gonna have her send you a copy of my
destroy your student loan debt
that's gonna help you walk through these
student loans but right now you need to
get rid of this car
so our rule of thumb casey that he's
using to do that is
if the car is more than half your annual
income or you can't be 100
debt free including the car within two
years
because of the car then it's time to get
rid of the car the second one is what
got you
obviously 19 000 is less than half of 53
000 so that'd be okay it's on the bubble
but it'd be okay to keep it
you shouldn't have bought it but it'd be
okay to keep it uh and pay your way out
of it the problem is you're not going to
be able to make debt free if you do keep
it within two years it's going to take
you three years
and so it is worth stepping down out of
that car and that's what anthony
that's how he made that decision really
quick so quickly
uh is those are two guidelines we use
because here's the deal
cars come and go but wealth
is built when you get rid of the
payments
the faster you get rid of the payments
the faster you can build wealth
and the faster you can buy a different
car
but right now you need a beater yeah
stay on the line kelly will take care of
you and get you a copy of that book